congratulations on the grammy nom man
thank you man appreciate that i've just
been in here working hard you see i'm
like locked in mine in this dark studio
right now
right there so you know but um thank you
man i'm
i've been really uh you know working
toward you know
getting to this level and uh i'm happy
that i'm finally getting recognition
that's the thing i mean you've been at
this for like years and years like how
does it feel to finally get a grammy
nomination
uh you know you know you do it for the
you know the love of it you know when
the accolades come you know you you
take them and respect them and accept it
so you know it's great man
like i said i'm i'm humble and i'm i'm
just glad that they invited me to the
party
yeah that's the thing i know drake
talked about
the idea that you know we shouldn't be
putting value in these awards you know
it's about the work and
maybe they aren't as relevant anymore
like do you still feel like the grammys
are
as relevant especially as you get a
grammy now i mean
it's relevant to me i got one great girl
yeah
drake got like 50 of them so when you
got like 50 of them i guess you could
say
that but you know to me man i'm you know
i'm happy this is a big moment for
myself and my family
and you know everybody else could feel
about you know how they feel about it
but i know that
myself and my family we're you know we
actually ecstatic
yeah what do you think of them moving
the grammys do you think that's the
right decision or delaying the grammys
oh yeah give me more time to get my
outfit together
have you guys have you planned it at all
yet what you're going to wear oh yeah
i'm going to definitely go with
a pink bunny rabbit easter suit there's
gonna be some pastel colors in there man
that's awesome have you prepared a
speech
uh yeah definitely got speech ready yeah
because i feel like i'm gonna win so i
had to i had to get my speech ready
yeah no i think you deserve to win so
hopefully you do win and so yeah the new
ep that you're working on
uh so you're gonna time that with the
release like with the grammys why are
you trying to time it with the
release of the grammys uh maybe i might
do that or
i might not i don't know maybe i just
might drop a song during grammy week i
mean man the way i feel right now man
alfredo's giving me so much momentum
i damn near probably don't have to drop
a lot of music this year but you know i
i am but
you know but uh i'm i'm kind of still
riding half that album
yeah yeah yeah so with the new music
like what's the sound sounding like i
mean
2020 was such a massive year in so many
ways in terms of the health crisis in
terms of black lives matter like
does that kind of stuff seep into your
music like when you're writing
um yeah definitely you know um i try
i'm not a super political um rapper
yeah but um for the most part um
i uh i say that uh you know you you
definitely rap
and uh write about what's going on
around you
um but i think you know my music always
you know i feel like
a lot of people that's like jumping on
that wave right now kind of late to the
party because i've been talking about
like injustices
and things like that in my music before
i was just doing it from a
street guy standpoint you know what i
mean like um
and you know that probably that could
have flown over some people's heads but
uh you know
you know with hard work and perseverance
i think that people are starting to get
the message now
yeah yeah what is the sound of the new
ep is it something different
um you know i mean if you know me man
you know that i'm one of the
most versatile guys in the game i think
i think i'm the most versatile rapper
period you know i'm saying guys like you
know um
uh kendrick and uh drake you know i
think you know
i think that you know i'm on at that
level of versatility
so uh you know i'm going in all kind of
different directions you know uh
different producers uh some of the usual
suspects as well so
i'm just you know i'm just working man
you know
i think i don't i'm blessed every day i
can get up and
come in my office and work and you know
and that's just what i do i don't take a
day for granted yeah have you found this
to be a motivating time like i've talked
to artists that
haven't recorded anything like over 2020
because just
and have you found this inspiring time
yeah definitely
um you know i'm nominated for the grammy
man so what's more inspiring than that
sure yeah
so i'm very locked in man and i you know
i
you know i got a lot of you know life
experiences to talk about i've had a lot
of life experiences under my belt for a
while you know that that's the basis and
the content
of my music so you know this is
definitely one
life experience for us all i mean you
know they just stormed the u.s capitol
yesterday so
you know it's plenty of things to talk
about and draw from
you know musically i think i think that
a lot of people
may not be as inspired because a lot of
people aren't
going outside as much and a lot of
artists ain't doing shows as much so you
know it's difficult maybe to draw
inspiration from that regard but you
know
i can you know i wrote raps in jail
still so i can write raps anywhere you
know
right yeah i love the collaboration with
uh big sean
i love the video too where'd you guys
come up with the concept of like the nba
champions
oh i was just shouting out kobe it was
really like
like a kobe and shaq concept you know i
did that one for kobe
yeah was that something that really
affected you his passing last year
yeah man i love kobe and uh you know
you're one of the
uh true competitors in life period not
just basketball you know what i'm saying
like you know
his mentality you know definitely
carries on to a lot of
you know other people other than uh
athletes
yeah what was like working with big sean
like what's it like when you collaborate
with another rapper
um i don't know most rappers are scared
of me so
they don't really normally collaborate
with me you know that's why i'm not on a
lot of songs you know i said a lot of
songs out you know i'll get a lot of
verses back you know
maybe i think guys are like scared to
rap with me and i think some guys are
just scared to be furious so i mean i
don't know man i think that um
a big the big sean collaboration was uh
you know 10 years in the making it was
long overdue we were both on a freshman
cover together
so uh you know we should have definitely
uh
did a song before but uh it um you know
timing and it happened when it was
supposed to happen and um
it was a great it was a great thing i
love big sean and what he brings to the
game um and
i appreciate them working with me yeah
so why do you think rappers are scared
of you
oh man i don't know man you know i kind
of got this dark aura around me man i
had that around me my whole career so i
mean um
i don't know you know i mean i think um
i come as advertised you know
yeah and you know what's the story about
so there's like a rapper that you
haven't named that like
wouldn't work with you or wanted to
charge you money to work with and now
they're coming calling because your new
like grammy nominations your success
i mean one thing about tables they turn
you know what i mean and i didn't say
that
kind of like call nobody out i just said
that as like
an example to other artists you know i
mean to you know kind of know your worth
you know what i mean
you know it's going to be like a lot of
guys in the game that's going to like
treat you unfairly you know what i mean
because of that status might be above
yours but you know and you got to
remember that when you get
you know i gotta constantly remind
myself you know like when you know when
you get to a certain point you gotta
sometimes uh uh look back and do good
things for other people as well you know
in the game and be
of service to somebody else so you know
that's how i looked at it you know i
mean it's definitely all the business
and you know i definitely
yeah make me offer doing music you know
doing songs to people and stuff like
that
but you know it's you know certain a
certain kind of money you know would be
it kind of
is it'll be it kind of looked as it's
like disrespect you know what i'm saying
so you know just like [ __ ] if i go
if i go to the store and try to uh and
you know try to get a bag of oranges and
try to charge you a thousand dollars for
them you'll be like damn man come on man
you're going
to you're kind of going to feel like
it's a slap in your face right you know
with that said you know i'm not arguing
with any man's prices or how they feel
about the work of their products so
you know nowadays i just take all of
that with you know and just
keep it moving you know me i only work
with people that want to work with me
organically and we got a
a vibe you know i don't play the uh you
know chase the artist down game
you know i don't know i mean i'll let it
hand r or something like labels that do
that you know what i mean if you want to
work with me then we're going to find a
way to work
all the games and playing and all of
that like now i don't even like get into
that with anybody
yeah have you seen a big change over the
last year i guess like with the success
like alfredo of more doors been open
like you're seeing
the fruit of your success oh yeah oh
yeah
i just did it i just did a disney song
today so yeah
i think that uh i think that things are
on the up and up with mickey mouse come
on
you know you on fire you know what i
mean i knew i was growing up when mickey
mouse called me today mickey mouse said
hey freddie i need you to do this thing
i did that sent it back to mr mickey
mouse
and it's all love man so you know i
think the things are going on up and up
i think that when things open up i
cannot wait to take my kids to disney
world you know so thank you mr mickey
mouse
that's awesome can you say what it's for
the song oh
not yet but me and mickey got something
cooking man
yeah that's awesome so i guess you can
talk about your new song that's going to
come out in a couple weeks gang signs
what can you tell us about that song
yeah definitely um it's a song that i
got with a schoolboy q
okay you know i mean uh shout out to
schoolboy q that's another guy we should
have collaborated a long time ago but
it happened when it was supposed to
happen and it was uh really organic and
um
it's a great record um you know it's
real smooth you know what i mean uh
schoolboy cube definitely the first guy
that i thought about when i made the
record you know what i mean because he
always like gang banging and stuff like
that you know i mean he's a gang maker
so
i was like all right gang signs let me
go get this gang banging rapper
do you have like a list of people that
you still want to collaborate with
oh yeah oh yeah
like you know i want to rap with great
rappers you know what i mean so you know
i definitely want to rap with the coles
the kendricks the
drakes guys guys of that nature you know
guys that you know got them you know
they got bars for sure
um uh it'd be my dream to do a song with
jay-z
yeah um you know there's a lot of guys
that i would like to collab with um
21 savage little baby you know guys like
that
um all kind of people man i'm uh
i'm very uh you know
avid listener music future future
probably my favorite artist
so i probably listen to him every day
from like working out and stuff like
that
but uh yeah man i just want to work with
whoever want to work with me man you
know what i mean and i'm a you know
a diligent worker you know i mean i'm a
got a good work ethic i don't come in
the studio
and and you know waste time at all so
who want to work with me
i'm with it
you